thank you
[Music]
there is this dude okay there's this
dude Mr Stephen Miller he is a former
Trump advisor who has recently filed a
civil rights complaint over woke
breakfast foods claiming that gay
Pop-Tarts or sexualizing kids obviously
Pop-Tarts bro yo Pop-Tarts there's a gay
Pop Tart what is this like rainbow
flavors yeah I didn't know Pop-Tarts had
a gender or a sexual sexual preference
yeah so yeah so they're doing campaigns
with you know what I mean is that Shaq
is that Shack
his level says I don't even know where
to go Shaq does endorsements for
everything dude he does that's why it
would have been funny
oh my God someone endorsement he doesn't
have does it say anywhere on the box
anything about gays so it just says
Pop-Tarts artist series neon pink block
party lemonade and then oh it's the gay
flag up there never alone okay and then
there's a pride flag up top as a
campaign thing so it's very very Pride
um stop putting the gay Pop Tarts in my
face is what they're saying tweeted we
are Beyond proud to partner with neon
powered by glad to create the limited
edition neon pink block party lemonade
Pride box featuring the crazy good and
crazy joyful designs of queer
illustrator Thaddeus coats
so not Shaq by the way
I know when you turned her around it was
this initial thing that I thought and I
saw him and I was like he's not sure
it's done you were explaining I mean
there's all there's gay kids out there
so he's he's gay
former Trump advisor no that's why I
said Don Campbell it kind of looks like
him
that's pretty good former Trump advisor
and current white nationalist Stephen
Miller has filed the complaint with the
equal employment opportunity commission
accusing Kellogg's of targeting children
through marketing campaigns that
politicize and sexualize its products
Miller's right-wing nonprofit America
First legal tweeted a list of such
products including a 2022 collaboration
with glad to make pink lemonade
Pop-Tarts with neon pink filling neon
pink obviously it's supposed to be I
mean do you think he's wrong Nick is
that the catchphrase do you think that
guy's wrong the white nationalist dude
saying that there's uh politicizing
Pop-Tarts well when you call him a white
nationalist I want to be on the side no
I'm just so sick of all these [__]
like why are you complaining about this
but I get it does he
it's just
everyone has a problem with [__]
everything dude it's just like preach
brother nice it's I hate these [__] I
kind of hate these articles a little bit
just because it's like sorry brother
yeah it's Anthony's fault this is
Stephen submitted by Steve the white
nationalist the last words because this
is like [__] it just this one actually
makes sense to me because like all right
so this collab right so for example Bud
Light you think trailer dude
when I think Pop Tart here we go I think
oh it could be gay I think childhood oh
so pop times were already dating you
well the color it's colorful it's by
it's like flamboyant it's sweet and in
your face you know
that super gay but the difference you
know it's a gear uh a breakfast snack
toaster strudel
kitchen your German accent please
I think I'm losing it actually
every time I do it it's worse dude Bud
Light is not for kids that's the
difference that that Pop-Tarts is mainly
for kids that's why I mean would you be
surprised though if Fruit Loops did a
collab with
the gay community's pretty gay I think
there's something cool about I like the
fact that any brand is willing to
partner with gay artists or gay creators
but I find it pandering when they have
to put flags all over and all this like
[__] yeah can't he just be a good artist
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like if they
partner with me I don't want to see the
[__] Filipino star on it like you
should just do a thing I think it's both
eyes for me it's that and then this guy
he's red what's the what's the formal
complaint that he's doing that it's uh
targeting kids and then but then where
does that formal complaint go where does
that go to the public and to the to us
and also who gives a [__] too you know
like well that's what it is I don't
think it's a I think it's just if a
company's gonna do that I think they
have to prove that they really [__]
mean it and they're not panders yeah
that's one thing that I would like
because I'm sure they're doing a first
day exactly afo also highlights
Kellogg's Pride cereal a limited edition
serial release in October 2022 which was
just rainbow heart shape cereal but with
all the cereal mascots on the box the
plate also cites drag queen RuPaul's
appearance on the cheese it's boxed in
September and Tony the Tiger posing with
transgender influencer Dylan Mulvaney at
the Tony Awards in June quote Kellogg's
is yet another big corporation that will
break the law and hurt its shareholders
interests to serve the Twisted woke
ideology of its officers and directors
Twisted that's the funny thing the
difference to me is that when I grew up
in the 90s as a [__] kid I loved
RuPaul because I thought RuPaul was
[__] cool but no but it didn't mean
that I was I had a different political
stance because of that nowadays it's
like you show RuPaul to prove a point
back in the day RuPaul was just dope
yeah I don't understand why now it has
to be like a dividing line yeah we all
just like Mrs Doubtfire it wasn't making
me yeah yeah but then aren't both sides
kind of pandering because like the the
Pop-Tarts is pandering towards that
Community but this guy's also pandering
towards the anti-wolp community by
having to say this long ass can
complaint about it and he's trying to
get all those people on board with him I
think that's fair actually yeah it's
like they're both doing the thing that
nobody wants like nobody cares about
that's what it looks like it looks like
two sides are using extremes to fight to
yeah but you know they want to keep it
in the middle yeah but like I get it
Pop-Tarts is trying to make sales by
pandering to like whatever and this
guy's trying to get attention for
whatever it is the middle seat doesn't
sell so yeah yeah may I add we're too
sensible here huh should we take a stab
yeah yeah
may I add Miller stumbled across these
marketing campaigns while investigating
Kellogg's for having too much diversity
in its ranks
AFL on Wednesday requested that too much
diversity they requested that the U.S
equal employment opportunity commission
investigate the carbohydrates producer
for racial discrimination against white
people specifically white men AFL
accused Kellogg's of promoting people
quote based on skin color at the expense
of others because of their skin color
and complain that they come company had
special programs for underrepresented
and underserved demographics such as
black people and women
so this guy's this guy's taking a strong
stance I just like when people were
recognized for what they did and that's
it and it's like oh you're good at this
that's what you are but then now it's
like oh you climbed Everest and you're
vegan like what gives a [__] if you
climbed it you climb that's cool yeah
okay the [__] you climb Everest yeah
it's such a it's such a weird thing that
like the thing that you are takes
precedence over the thing that you
worked really hard to achieve and that's
the part that I'm like I don't care
about that that's a good take that's my
take
[Laughter]
yep what happened catalogs is a Seventh
Day Adventist whoa he made that
Kellogg's cereal thingy but you know
what you know what also is another Point
too is that like you remember like as an
Asian if you start achieving things then
Asian coalitions come after you and they
go oh come to our event and then show
everyone why being Asian's so great so I
can assume too that if you're an artist
and you're gay then the gay community
will want you to Champion for them so
it's a lot of pressure I'm sure too yeah
damn why does God be about that though
it's like just make it about the art or
like about it I think because people
um
identify with their tribe much more
quicker than anything so then like when
they see an achievement they see
themselves achieving so if you're like
being seen you know how they say that oh
I feel seen and [__] yeah it's like
that's that's not you that's like an
Asian guy you don't even know this guy
so you're saying it's like a more primal
thing like a more private a thousand
percent and I think that's why it works
with marketing because
um if it's like the Hot Topic right now
and you're like oh I'm one of the
companies that'll do this and if you're
putting like Pride flags on a cup and
you can sell that easily to a built-in
demographic it's kind of like hey I know
a lot of girls that like Hello Kitty if
I get the same exact cup put a hell cool
little Hello Kitty sticker and get that
license in I can sell that for like
extra so it's all it's all business okay
yeah you know what would be funny is is
like let's say they did that to like
make Asian Pop-Tarts and they put a
[__] rice hat in the [__] thing
like that's insane that's probably what
it feels like you know like it's not
it's super corny oh black sesame
Pop-Tarts
on the side yeah it's pretty
understandable that while they are doing
marketing and while might seem corny
some uh I guess like some groups are
willing to ride that still because
they're they feel oppressed so it's like
oh even though this isn't ideal it's
something yeah yeah it's because it's a
whole spectrum of different thinking
people also too like if these companies
didn't make massive amounts of money by
doing these campaigns they probably
wouldn't do it it would die out you see
every you see every single yeah they
everyone's doing it because I'm sure
it's funny how they like fight over all
this [__] but they don't even talk about
the ingredients and harmful chemicals
that are in all the foods that are
[__] everybody up but we could talk
about the world over here over here yeah
yeah yeah let's let's fight over [__]
that doesn't do anything here yeah I
just feel like we're moving farther away
from things being coincidentally
tolerable which is when I think real
tolerance kicks in when you didn't know
that something was this but you already
liked it where it's like oh I like this
food what is it oh it's frozen it's gay
food it's gay guy food oh no way cooking
it's like it's the other order where
it's like hey this is gay food so you
can't not like it yeah
it gets kind of strange it's like you
might have liked it anyway yeah yeah
because there's a stance and a belief
and an identity it might have already
been cool like like when you meet a
person that's like let's say you like
know a nice Filipino person you
automatically just like all Filipinos
more if you got [__] up by a Filipino
you got bullied by one you probably
don't like them it's just all racism
it's all like you know that just
tolerance just happens
but then if we beat you to the
experience and tell you hey you just
have to like Filipinos you're going to
be predisposed to not right right and
that's because you're being forced to
you can't make your own judgments
yeah it's a little bit weird I don't
really like Filipinos most hey I'm
working on you
when was the last time you had a
Pop-Tart oh [__] Filipino last night
last night dude
foreign